i love this movie so much i was cracking
up the whole time but it still had so
much heart and you two
are the heart and soul of this movie
so for anyone who might not be up to
speed there might be a little confusion
for people who are like wait there was a
suicide squad movie before now there's
the suicide squad
how do you describe this movie to people
daniella i would say
that everyone can tell a story and
everyone that tells the story
always uh puts a little bit of
themselves
in the story and we can say
with this the suicide squad is james
version
and for me it's truly a masterpiece for
me i can't imagine like
other suicide squad uh made
from like anybody else sorry for
everybody else
well wait what james is so great at is
he takes these really obscure characters
that people don't might not even know
and makes us all fall in love with them
so idris for you what did you know about
your character
in advance and i don't know if this is
true but i read you signed on without
knowing
who you were playing yeah this is really
really true
um um ash i um didn't know what
character i was playing but i knew the
type of character and i knew
the position he played within the
storyline
so that's all i needed to understand and
i signed on
uh but i did know that you know he was
uh the first guy to you know put
superman in hospital because he's shot
superman
and that's why he's in jail and that was
very intriguing and also became
a little bit of a motivation in some of
my scenes and my character development
a lot of people thought you were taking
over for will smith's character
deadshot what did you make of those
rumors those movements would be natural
because you know will said he wasn't
um going to be joining the second movie
so it was quite you know
natural for the audiences of fans to
think that i would be
taking over the deadshot character
because the dead shot character lived
in the of a movie but
i was you know really satisfied that
james didn't want to do that
um i didn't want to do that um deadshot
is a great character and will slays it
so
i was really keen the audience and fans
kept that rumor going
surprise you know your characters have
like this really kind of special bond
did you feel that on set or did you guys
get to do anything together
offset just to secure that bond any
offset moments you can tell me about we
had
so much fun uh we would tell
each other the worst jokes that we
ever heard about and we would just
push each other just to like i don't
know
to provoke each other and that bond um
like the bond that you see in the movie
it's the friendship that we have
also off off camera idris like james
you're kind of navigating the
marvel to dc crossover i'm curious if
you've been keeping up with the
multiverse stuff that's been going on
over there
because now i'm feeling like there's
actually a big chance we could see
heimdall again
what do you think is that possible i
mean you know i think that
the the the con the constraints of the
sort of
superhero uh universe are
none so everything is possible
um and i think that you know heindel is
an amazing character
and still exists you could be like the
marvel dc daddy just like doing them
both you know
hey i like that marvel vc daddy that's a
great name for a band
daniela tell me about i i want to hear a
little bit more about rat catcher's
two's powers because she can control
rats but did you were there rat actors
on set yes i can show you a picture that
i have
here with me please do my wallpaper for
like since i shot the movie so this is
sebastian
and he was all the time like wanted to
cuddly a cuddle with me and yeah it was
difficult because
uh red catcher two has like sebastian
every day with her so
for her it wasn't a big thing or a big
deal
and for me i was so excited for it so
like between takes i would be
oh sebastian and then action okay yeah
he's here
i don't care what were the rats actual
names wasn't one like crisp
rat crisp rat jaws
and my favorite one was squeaky oh my
gosh i love that
i heard they're like um like the closest
thing to dogs or something like rats as
pets or
yeah they're really smart uh actually
they can be trained
and like the rats that we had were
trained
like to be standing up uh to stay on my
shoulder
and another one was like the smartest
that could be
like if we call them uh they like he
could come
she could come um so yeah it's it's
amazing
robert dubois he's in prison for putting
superman in the icu with the kryptonite
bullet i'm not joining your suicide
squad
we'll see idris what would you like to
see
bloodsport do next it wouldn't be next
it would be what
came before i would be really interested
you know
to see why he went to jail why
did he shoot superman i would love to
see that
narrative come alive daniella how about
you for you with rat catcher too
she had the opportunity to talk about
his father
so i would love to see a little bit more
about it
but i would love also to see ratcatcher
like
learning from i don't know why not
bloodsport
how to shoot a gun how to fight with
someone
i would love to see like her debut as a
super villain for real
you